we've told you in the past that
Democratic primary voters don't seem to
have much of a choice this year there
are an awful lot of candidates in the
race but all of them seem to have
identical far-left positions on the
issues that matter on immigration and
climate change gun control the economy
you name it until yesterday that was our
view and then we watched last night's
democratic debate and we're gonna have
to revise that assessment it turns out
that not everyone in the field is a
lunatic we stand corrected on that in
fact there are a couple of sane ones
unfortunately they're getting crushed
watch for example what happened when
congressman Tim Ryan tried to remind his
fellow Democrats that most Americans
don't actually support open borders much
less giving free taxpayer-funded health
care to foreign nationals who break our
laws Ryan suddenly became the most
unpopular kid at the party
watch now in this discussion already
tonight we've talked about taking
private health insurance away from union
members in the industrial Midwest we've
talked about decriminalizing the border
and we've talked about giving free
health care to undocumented workers when
so many Americans are struggling to pay
for their health care I quite frankly
don't think that that is an agenda that
we can move forward on and win we've got
to talk about the working-class issues
the people that take the shower after
work who haven't had a raise in 30 years
I think we focus on that will win the
election Thank You congressman
congressman Network your response sir
not a lot of applause in fact dead
silence it turns out the Democrats in
the room didn't want to talk about
working-class issues or people as Tim
Ryan put it who take a shower after work
progressives wrote those voters off as
disgusting a long time ago they're poor
they're uneducated and yet at the same
time they are deeply privileged it goes
without saying that they must be racist
every single one of them Tim Ryan is
probably racist for thinking about them
the modern Democratic Party has zero use
for these kind of people
they've been excluded from the emerging
al Sharpton private equity coalition
that defines the Democratic Party so
apparently is anyone who cares about
what voters think several times last
night Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders personally attacked any
candidate who dared point out there
might be a limit to how many on
popular ideas you can impose on a nation
that's supposed to be a democracy the
very idea that you'd have to win popular
support for your policies seem to enrage
them Warren especially at one point they
all but accused a CNN anchor of being a
secret Republican plant probably the
first time that's ever happened you do
not support Medicare for all
it's Senator Warren correct you just not
lack the will to fight for Jake your
question is the Republican talking point
what you want to do instead is find the
Republican talking point of a made-up
piece of some other part and say oh we
don't really have to do anything talking
points in order to talk with each other
about how to best provide so what she
did saw that last clip that really was
the story of the whole night Elizabeth
Warren jumping up and down and barking
at anyone who asked too many questions
or seemed insufficiently the left-wing
now not everything Elizabeth Warren says
is wrong we actually like her views on
manufacturing and trade for example
they're smart and we've said so
repeatedly on the show we're not
partisan actually but holy smokes is
weren't unbearable in a lot of ways
pedantic dishonest nasty as hell watch
how she treated former Maryland
Congressman John Delaney who's by the
way one of the nicest men in politics
when he encouraged his fellow Democrats
to make promises they can actually keep
I think Democrats win when we run on
real solutions not impossible promises
when we run on things that are workable
not fairy tale economics you know I
don't understand why anybody does to all
the trouble of running for president of
the United States just to talk about
what we really can't do and shouldn't
fight for
so if you're not a red in the face
dishonest demagogue Elizabeth Warren
thinks you're a wuss when Montana
Governor Steve Bullock questioned the
wisdom of open borders with free health
care for everyone
Warren twisted his point into something
completely unrecognizable see if you can
follow this you are playing into Donald
Trump's hands a sane immigration system
needs a sane leader and we can do that
without decriminalizing providing health
care for everyone you're saying is if
you or the law was matter and it matters
if we say our law is that we would lock
people up who come here seeking refuge
who come here seeking asylum that is not
a crime laws matter Elizabeth Warren yes
of all people just said that and
amazingly nobody in the room dared push
back against her saying that there are a
lot of weak men in the Democratic Party
not just on last night's debate stage
it's one of the party's biggest problems
actually a normal candidate would have
roasted her laws matter please Elizabeth
Warren's entire immigration position is
built on the premise that laws don't
matter at all that's the whole point of
it if laws mattered we wouldn't have 22
million illegal aliens living inside our
borders Democrats wouldn't be working
really 24/7 to give amnesty to every
single one of them which they are if
laws mattered we wouldn't have sanctuary
cities if flaws mattered Democrats
wouldn't be sharing Spanish language
guides telling the illegals how to evade
immigration enforcement if laws mattered
Kate Steinle and Molly Tibbets would
still be alive in a night of absurd
declarations Elizabeth Warren claiming
the mantle of the law was the most
incredible but there was nobody there to
call her on it the moderates had all
been gelded and silenced